Hey everyone, I'm here at SAGE Summit 2015 in New Orleans
and I just came out of a great session with Stephen Kelly
and Colin Powell and Deepak Chopra
and they were talking about some great strategies
and ideas to help you grow your business
and I'm going to share with you some of the highlights
from that speech today.
If you ask people globally if they love what they do every day in their jobs,
only 20% of people say yes.
In the United States alone, we have $300 billion lost a year
from disengaged or actively disengaged people in their jobs.
What's the difference between actively disengaged and disengaged?
The actively disengaged are not only unhappy,
but they come to work with the intention of making everyone else unhappy.
So this is a huge burden in our jobs.
If a supervisor or a manager ignores their employee,
a particular employee, the disengagement score goes up by 45%.
If on the other hand, they don't ignore them,
but they criticize them, actually the employee gets better,
the disengagement rate falls to less than 20%
because people would rather be criticized than ignored.
But if you notice a single strength that they have,
the disengagement rate goes down to less than 1%.
In the job world, you have to focus on three things.
You have to have inspired teams,
and inspiration comes from you, the leader of the workforce.
And that is you give them attention, which means you listen to them,
appreciation, affection, to some extent acceptance, even for their weaknesses.
You make sure that you all have shared vision,
and then you complement each other's strengths,
because not everybody has the same strengths.
That's what a good sports team is,
so as people who give employment to others,
think like a sports coach, shared vision, complementing strengths,
emotional connections.
If you do that, your business will be very successful.
In fact, of the three constituencies that go to make an effective business,
which is investors, employees, and customers,
your employees are number one.
And your customers will be happy if your employees are happy,
and your investors will be happy if your customers are happy.
You might be your own investor.
You can actually track the success of a business
just by what is called employee turnover rate.
If the employee turnover rate is very high, you better watch out.
And then there are other things.
Engaging with your community,
but now you could have a global community, even with a small business.
Making sure you connect with other people who have strengths
that comfortable with yours,
and that also is available now through LinkedIn
and many other social networks.
And taking care of yourself,
which means getting enough sleep every day,
managing stress through whatever means you do.
For me, it's meditation.
Making sure you get exercise.
Remaining emotionally healthy with love, compassion, joy,
equanimity, and proper nutrition.
If you pay a little attention to just these things,
your personal well-being, your social well-being,
your community well-being, career well-being, financial well-being,
you're off to a good start.
One day when I was Secretary of State, I got bored.
And I wanted to go downtown.
And I wanted to meditate or go away somewhere else.
But I decided to go down to the garage.
Because the garage and state department are small,
considering all the cars that come in every morning.
And I wanted to see how the guys did it.
So I escaped my bodyguards and assistants to the back elevator and went to the garage.
The garage would run out of contract employees.
All in the rest.
Make a few bucks over minimum wage.
And so I'm wandering around and they stop me.
And so they come over.
Mr. Secretary, you lost me.
I'll help you get back upstairs.
I said, I'm fine, thank you.
And they said, what are you doing down here?
I wanted to talk to you guys.
I wanted to see how you got all the cars in the morning.
I know there are so many that you have to stack them one, two, and three.
And two and three can't leave until one leaves.
So how do you decide every morning who's number one, who's number two, who's number three?
Is the job okay?
Too much carbon dioxide?
Number five, sir.
Thank you so much.
Well, tell me, how do you decide who's number one?
They said, Mr. Secretary, you kind of go like this.
When you pose in the morning, if you stop by us, if you go over here one day, as you look at me,
and if you smile, I need to say, good morning, how are you?
You're number one.
But we don't know what you're number one.
That's all we're here for.
I'm number one.
There's really plenty.
In that car is an assistant secretary who is here in the organization, in charge of many countries.
Outside that car is his different contract employee, Hugo Soren in the donation.
They both have dreams, fears, anxieties, and ambitions.
Both of them.
The one in the car has the option of helping the one outside the car achieve his dreams and ambitions
and minimizing his fears.
And so that's their structure in the organization.
But at that moment of good morning, they're equal.
They're two human beings recognizing each other as human beings
and pay and respect solely for the fact that we are united as human beings
and together we can accomplish great things.
Thank you all.
Deepak, how do you attract the best people and keep the best people?
I personally recommend seven rules that have expanded on the seven spiritual laws for businesses.
The first is be a really good listener.
And that means be a good observer of what's happening in the company, the employees and the customers.
Listen to emotional cues because lots of times people will be unhappy but you can read their body language.
Listen with your soul. Take time to reflect on what is the zeitgeist at the moment in the business world.
One of the things that I noticed as part of the zeitgeist is contribution to community.
Your own company does that. Two percent of your income goes to supporting people.
And so look to how you can contribute to your community.
Second, use emotional intelligence.
Emotional intelligence means the ability to feel emotions, empathy and communicating in a way that doesn't make people feel insecure.
Third, expand your awareness. Constantly ask yourself what are we observing, what are we feeling, what's the current need in the business and what's the remedy?
How do we fulfill that need?
You can ask that of your customers. What are you observing? What are you feeling? What do you need? How can I help you to fulfill that need?
Third, be action oriented. It's good to philosophize but you have to be a role model for action.
Develop smart goals every year. Smart, I use as an acronym, stretch more than you can reach.
Make everything measurable. Make sure that your team, your employees also agree.
Keep a record of your progress and set time limits.
Empower yourself with self-esteem. I read in this book yesterday that you have to be immune to criticism even though you are responsive to feedback.
Because criticism can let you down if you take it personally. Take responsibility for your health.
As a 12 year old sweeping the floor, packing coffee bags, I knew from that very early age the connection between work, life and family.
And the great story of personal sacrifice for business owners.
So why do we care at Sage so much for businesses like yours?
Around the world, small and medium businesses are the lifeblood of the economy.
Yes, in this USA alone, 66%, yes two thirds of the 12 million new jobs created since 2010 were created by small and medium businesses like yours.
Many of you work more than 6 yards a week. You are the first ones in and you are the last ones out every day.
You give up your holidays, you mortgage your homes and you invest your life savings in your businesses.
All to provide for your families, to create a legacy, to pursue your passion, to live your dreams.
You are the true heroes of the economy, the risk takers, the winners in America and every economy around the world.
This is truly a noble cause for prosperity. And that is why, that is why we care so much.
At Sage, we feel such a huge sense of responsibility as your trusted technology partner.
We are your champion. We will fight for you. We will fight for the little guys.
We will deliver products for you that let you work the way that you want to work.
And that is why we are here today, here in New Orleans at the largest small and medium business conference in the world.